hello everyone and welcome to round 10
of the Magnus Invitational we are
continuing our coverage with the match
Fabiana Caruana versus Hikaru Nakamura
and it is Game 1 of their match and
already quite the game so without
further ado let's check it out and we're
gonna check out the distending after
this round so Fabi with the white pieces
opens with d4 and interestingly Nakamura
again sticks with the same line he
played against both Magnus and against
the alavesa
so Knight of 6 we have c4 e6 Knight to
f3 and b5 so the Queens gambit declined
in the Knight to c3
he goes for Bishop to e7 and now Bishop
f4 same as ali riza in Magnus played
against Hikaru with castles and III now
at Knight B to d7 and c5 now if you
remember that line where we mentioned
you cannot go b6 because of c6 so first
Nakamura blocks it with c6 and now both
Magnus and fallujah played h3 against
Hikaru here but here Fabi prepares h4
and it is a new move in the position so
obviously Fabi knew that he Cara would
once again repeat this slide so I don't
know if I mentioned it is as of move 8
that we have a completely new game so
Hikaru continues as he usually does
we've be six challenging the c5 pawn
which may or may not be overextended
before we have a 5 attacking that be for
pawn again and now a 3 and now Knight to
e4 by Nakamura attacking the the c3
Knight here we have Knight captures by
Fabi
D captures and the Knights that a 5
where Nakamura just captures as the c c6
ponies under attack you could defend it
with this but then you allow White's the
switch is Knight over to c4 to put
additional pressure on b6 so instead
captures captures and the Queen to d5
now a very active square for Nakamura's
Queen and should Fabi go for something
like rook to c1 to prepare Bishop to c4
because the white rope left the F out
black is very happy to close with b5 so
instead rush of the e2 Fabi just
continues Castle the continues to castle
and now Bishop to e6 here Nakamura
simply trades everything off we have
castles Bishop characters we have Queen
captures and now a character's on b4
with a cap person B for B
sorry a Kaptur son b4b captors and c5-b
captures and now Nakamura goes for
worship captures on c5 which if if pawn
captures then you recapture here and you
wanna pawn but fob Bobby says two can
play that game
he goes for Bishop captures and g7
instead now if King captures you can
just play D captures and uncie five
which is what what happened in the game
Hikaru captured as his rook was under
attack so D captures on c5 and now not
grabbing the pawn if you grab the point
you just trade this for for this point
just queen g4 check picks it up and I so
not not really doing anything so Quinta
e5 instead keeping an eye on the point
here but now rook 8d one by foe be
preparing rook to d4 again to put
additional pressure on this efore pawn
so look the a5 now nakamura goes for the
c5 pawn with with the rook and now rook
the d4 that's not a rook rook the d4 as
planned so King Day h8 finally getting
the King away from this Queen g4 check
and now g3 by Fabi now and finally rook
characters on c5 so for the moment and
Nakamura is up upon and it's a very nice
past C pawn
so rook the b1 by Fabi Fabi will now use
this knock Morris up upon and has a
pasty pond but his king is also a bit
vulnerable so Bobby will try to shift
all all the rooks and the Queen into the
attack so look the d5 nakamura now is
already of course the trade material as
he is up upon so rook the c-4 now Bobby
just attacks the pawn
we have c5 the point is now nicely
defended here and the Queen to c2 Fabi
adds more attackers to the pawn and f5
by nakamura getting rid of his well
maybe weak f7 pawn and in the future who
knows maybe you can even push to f4
we looked a 4x5 e now preparing some
nice rook lifts as you've seen in the
thumbnail of the video and now rook F to
d8 are preparing to go down with the
rooks work to d2 maybe an idea if the B
rook leaves the background maybe even
rook to d1 check but it's still unclear
how you will how you will get to the
Queen to join the attack so here F Abby
says there's no danger along the back
rank just
to be seven and now of course he wants
to play rock a seven and try and check
me the black king
so rook five to d7 of course Nakamura
cannot allow that and now look the a
eight by Fabi a nice idea that now
forces the trade of one of the rooks but
one of his rocks will remain in the
attack so here Nakamura decides to
capture the b7 pawn with the idea that
the king will be very safe on g7 so rock
characters did with check King g7 and
now King to g2 Fabi also improves the
safety of his King and now rook the c7
Nakamura now puts a rogue behind the
passed pawn and he's ready to push it we
have Quinta a for now saying do you
start pushing and allow Quinta yet which
will result in some very very nasty
checks in the back rank or do you do
start defending so here
c4 does seem like the way to go but it
looks very scary and especially if
you're alone although on the clock so
instead a Nakamura went back Queen to f6
so the Queen can also help out with the
defense and the Queen to aid by Fabi
King to h6 and now comes Luke to d6 so
like I said I guess it was better to
just start pushing the pawn as now you
are really in a position where we have
to defend and the problem is we remove
like rook to e7 you no longer I have a
rogue behind a passport and you're very
passive here for example Queen c8 goes
after the pawn and now if you persist in
defending it would Queen to e5 now you
can even lose the game Queen f8 check a
connect with the rook you have to move
rook g7 now rook the c6 again with a
double attack on the pawn here and if
you try something like c4 to get it to
give it away from there rook c5 now
attacks the Queen Queen moves and now
rogue back to c7 with a double attack on
the rook and the problem is even if you
retreat the Queen rook f7 is deadly
threatening rook to f6 check fall by
Queen captures here and just a whole lot
of complications that there's no reason
for for black to go into so instead of
rook to e7
King to g7 Nakamura goes back with the
king and now again not capturing the
pawn right away but rather we have Queen
b8 also you could go for just rook
captures any
six but then Fabi thought that okay
Queen f7 I grabbed the pawn but maybe he
can force a queen trade here you could
force a trade of rooks here with
characters and captures but then again
after King age seven you capture here
and you get this where five is up upon
but it's a queen important game so very
unclear if you will be able to do
anything here
so the keep chance is alive Queen back
to b8 by Fabi now attacks the rook and
rook back to f7 by nakamura rook the c6
now preparing to grab on c5 and now rook
to d7 and again Fabi in no rush to
capture the pawn he just goes Luke the
c8 once again as both of them are very
long low on time you constantly have to
check what happens after Luke to G so it
is very useful and you can always grab
the the c5 pawn so King back to h6 by
Nakamura and only now rook captures on
c5 so now Fabiola manator the past C
pawn and it's now equal material with
Fabi spawn structure much better and
hickories King is a bit loose here so
rook the g7 now Hikaru knows that well
it's probably a draw let's just defend
this and now rook the c6 again a Fabi
will try to create some chances here we
have ripped the e7 not allowing well not
allowing a double attack but also
already defending it twice we look back
to see it and hear a Nakamura played
rook to f7 but rook the f7 although it
seems like it guards from rook to f8 and
that everything is okay it's actually a
move that loses he cover the game so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it this well winning idea for Fabi
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it's not an easy idea
to find and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
it's a rook to e8 point is that now
you're threatening Queen d6 and just
grabbing the the e6 pawn and it's not
easy to defend it for example if you try
something like let's say you you you
make a slow move like the King g6 just
Queen b6 and there's no more defending
it
so rook to e7 is not possible so instead
after this rook to e8 move Nakamura
immediately went
to East rook to e7 but now comes a
fabi's main idea Queen to d8 you cannot
you cannot trade because the Queen hangs
so Luke back to f7 here but now Fabi has
just a monster move
so even pause the video once again and
try to find this beautiful idea again
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those who were able to do that
congratulations on spotting the move
that Fabi missed in the game and for
those of you they just want to enjoy the
show it's of course rook captures on e6
which wins the Queen and of course if
you capture that's no better then comes
Queen to g5 checkmate so the reason fab
you missed this is because he found
another winning line and he decided that
there's no reason to look any further he
played Queen to d6 now just threatening
to pick up this exponent when the Queen
so king h5 by Nakamura but rook captures
an e6 now one point falls Queen to g7
and now Queen to f4 again a threatening
some very nasty ideas so here look the
f6 nakamura of course once the wants to
try and force a queen and pawn endgame
but now comes g4 with check so what do
you do here if you capture you just lose
the rook so that's no good if you
capture if you capture with the Queen
it's not much better just Queen
characters in g4 and then the rook is
left a defenseless
so here King to h4 King captures on h4
was played King to g6 is no better if
you go King to g6 then Queen g5 check
King to have seven and now you just win
the Queen with rookie 7 check you force
the King back and now Queen captures
here so that would be also very
unfortunate so nakamura played king
captures on h4 but now comes g5 with
check and it was in this position
unmoved 47 that Hikaru Nakamura resigned
the game and Fabi takes Game 1 of their
match so it was a very intense and it's
a really important of course match for
both of them as each of them I think has
a chance to overtake Magnus in the
leaderboard so we'll see what happens in
the other three games so here you resign
the only move is king age 5 and I was
just real characters on f6 as now at the
point guards the rook you are down the
rook and of course there is no defense
against rook to h6 so really really
wild game could have gone either way
it's it's really amazing how Fabia
allowed Nakamura to have that past
c-pawn but India and Nakamura couldn't
really do anything with it so excellent
preparation by Fabi and he definitely
knew his way around the position better
than the Nakamura sure once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Terrence Nolan Yan or ask Steve
Wacha our Thomas Connors and Roland
Miller for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I'm thank you for watching
and I will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day